Hello everyone, I hope that you're good.
Happy New Year. In this video I'm going
to analyze Bitcoin's price action in the
short term. So, basically I'm going to
try to project what could potentially
happen next. And as you know, this
projection here I've been having it for
over the last
two or three weeks. So far it's playing
out. And also in this video I'm going to
tell you if I'm still favoring this
projection or what other scenarios what
other triggers I have in mind.
And for that I think it's important to
mention that the current structure is a
very tight range. This is the daily time
frame. We've been ranging here for over
the last six weeks really.
The resistance is 94K and the current
support really is 84K.
But
consider this low potentially going to
be taken out. That's 80 80,000 dollars,
okay?
And
I'm going to go straight to the point. I
don't really see Bitcoin recovering from
here towards all-time highs. I see more
likely
that either Bitcoin goes straight away
and sweep these lows here. What we also
have a weak
a long week in the daily time frame.
Remember that weeks tend to get filled
at least 96% of them do, okay? Only 4%
of them never get filled. But eventually
they do. So, I'm not sure if we are
going to go straight towards that level
and then recover from there or if first
we could see some kind of recovery up to
100K and then price could again drop.
You know,
fill this week, maybe sweep these lows
and then go towards all-time highs.
But that's my main idea at the moment
and is that Bitcoin I don't see it
recovering to all-time highs from here
without first having to attack this
level here around 80K.
Okay? Fill that week, maybe sweep those
lows. We all know that there is a lot of
liquidity always below the local low and
above the local high. So, sweeping those
lows would be
a very efficient move
before taking price to to the upside.
So, I'm still going to favor the idea
that price needs to take this area
first, all right?
Now, my triggers really are very simple.
In this area here that we're in the
middle of the range, I'm doing nothing.
I haven't been trading really for the
last weeks, okay? There is no more to
trade here.
Now, if price was to drop,
I would really be looking to trade this
area here. I'm going to mark it in the
chart with a circle.
So,
that is the area that I will be looking
to trade. That it will be after the
sweep of the lows gets confirmed and
price gets back above this low. That's
what I'll be looking
to enter again into the into the market
because
if price was to drop below this low and
consolidate below it for quite some time
without recovering that low, without
reclaiming it, then that would mean that
price
is going to go down because this has now
become resistance.
All right? So, keep that in mind. Don't
try to catch um
a falling knife if if if that ends up
being the case, okay? Just be patient.
That's what I would recommend. And if
instead price wants to go first, then I
need to look what is going to happen
here at 94K. That's the local
resistance. I think everybody can see
that, you know, there has been a lot of
uh reactions from that level as support
and then now as resistance. So,
that is our local resistance and then we
have another resistance that is our high
time frame resistance that has 100,000
dollars
in Bitcoin, okay?
You can see here support support support
support. That's four times.
And then if price gets there, it's very
possible that and this is the trade that
I'll be looking at, you know, if price
can reclaim the local resistance and
test it as a support, then that's what
I'll be opening a small long towards the
high time frame resistance where we
would see maybe a
a rejection. So, that is the upside case
that I'll be trading that I'll be
looking to trade, sorry.
But
right now at 89,000 dollars, I'm not
really
um
interested in trading this because price
can either go up or down. Really, there
is no much of a hedge here right now,
okay? We're in no man's land in my
opinion.
And
why why is the high time frame
resistance at 100,000? Well, basically
because it's a psychological level.
Psychological levels like 100,000,
110,000, 90,000,
80,000. You can see that that's the
level where, you know, Bitcoin has
stopped dumping.
Those areas are round numbers and
traders they usually place
their buy and sell orders are round
numbers at psychological levels.
Practically nobody is, you know, putting
a sell order
or a short order in this case at
101,000.
No, people are going to put at 100K,
you know? Or they're going to put a buy
order at 92K.
No, they're going to put at 90K. Or in
this case, they didn't put at 81K or
82K. They put at 80K.
80,600 I is the level
where price bounced from, all right?
80,000 is not the same as 81,000.
So,
that's why you can see a lot of
reactions at these psychological levels.
And that's why if price recovers from
here, you have to be very cautious that
this doesn't become a room for
liquidity. A room for liquidity is when
you see a move, it's a move a false move
really to try to gather the liquidity of
one side before
pulling the next move that is the real
move to the opposite side, okay? So, the
move is going to become more efficient
because it gathers the liquidity of one
extreme. You know, you have to
understand that you are hitting stop
losses, you are trapping traders and
then price is going to move into the
right direction
where
the target is, okay? So, right now that
we're at the mid of the range, you could
see the room for liquidity to the
downside here. A sweep of the lows, that
would be a room for liquidity because
the real move is to the upside, okay?
So, that is the move that you want to
trade after. Now, you don't want to open
here a short blindly because the room
for liquidity might be first to go up,
okay?
Trap traders here. They think that the
recovery is going to happen before
pulling the move down, sweep those lows
and then price can go up.
All right? So, here really at the mid
range, there is nothing really
interesting. Now,
if you don't mind, let me take you to
October 2019
where I think that there is a price
action
that is quite similar in my opinion
and it's what I'm looking
for it to happen, okay?
This here.
Okay? So, you can see that price
drops aggressively
for some days. Then you see a very tight
range here between this support that
I've marked and this resistance. You see
a deviation that could be a room for
liquidity.
Then price sweeps these lows and
recovers.
All right? So, that's what I'm looking
for. I don't think that price can
recover
like this now. I think first we are
likely to see a red big candle followed
by a big green candle to recover.
Okay? That's what I'm looking in the
case of Bitcoin right now. So, if we go
back
to
the current price,
it's going to take me a while.
Sorry.
We are in here, okay?
So, again,
I don't really see Let me remove all of
these so
it's cleaner.
I don't really see
a recovery like this
happening.
Okay? That's not what I'm really seeing.
I would imagine that it's more likely
that price
drops first,
recovers,
okay? And that's when it can start
fighting these resistances and go up.
That's what I'm looking in the case of
Bitcoin. That's what I think is more
likely. Now, it doesn't mean it's going
to happen. It's just my opinion and it's
here for you to
uh criticize it. So, um feel free to
tell me what you think is going to
happen. This is my view on Bitcoin.
Um if price
goes up, I'm not going to really trust
it, okay? But I'm open to trade these
local resistance to high time frame
resistance trade. This is a small long
here, okay? I'm willing to trade that
move.
But I'll be very concerned around these
levels, okay? That price doesn't drop
again towards this long week that we
have in the daily time frame that is
very important and this potential sweep
of the lows, okay?
Before price can continue go up. So,
that is my view on Bitcoin at the
moment. Thank you so much for watching,
guys. And I'll see you soon.